احتجاجات وايران تدخل اسبوع عن جديده
والغضب الشعبي في الشارع ما زال مستمرا
كما في الاسابيع الماضيه اليوم شهدت شوارع
مدينتي كرج واراك حضور كفيفا خلال مراسم
ذكرى اربعينيه مقتل الشابه حديث نجا في
والشاب مهرشاد شهيدي على يد القوات
الامنيه بعض المتظاهرين نشروا لقطات فيديو
لمواطنين متوجهين الى مقبره كرج للمشاركه
في مراسم اربعينيه نجفيه وفي مواجهه
القوات الامنيه ردد الحاضرون الشعارات ضد
النظام مثل هذا العام مدم وخامس
[تصفيق]
قوات الامين
في مراسم احياء ذكرى الشابه حديث نجفي
واطلقت الغاز المسير للدموع للتفريق
المجتمعين بينما قال محتجون ان السلطات
الامنيه استهدفت بالرصاص الحريقه
المشاركين في المراسم
[موسيقى]
ومع تواصل المظاهرات وجهها 40 محاميا
ايرانيا في مجال حقوق الانسان انتقادات
علنيه للسلطات معربين عن اعتقادهم بان
النظام سيسقط خاصه وان القمع لم يعد يخيف
المحتاجين المحامون المنتشرون داخل وخارج
ايران قالوا في بيانه ان الحكومه غريقه في
وهم اسقاط الاصوات بالقمع والاعتقال
والقتل الا ان طوافنا الناس سيسقط الحكومه
في النهايه حسب ما جاء في البيان واعربت
منظمات حقوق انسان عن الخشيه من ان
يواجهها من هم داخل البلاد من هؤلاء
المحامين خطر الاعتقال بسبب البيان الذي
وقع عليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي مقال تحليليه
في ايران بدا يتفكك وان مرشد ايران سيكون
مرغما على تقديم التنازلات لكن براي
اجنتشيوس لن يكون الاصلاح في قضيه الحجاب
خيارا سهلا لانها مني واستنادا على
تصريحاته يعتقد انه بمجرد تقديم التنازلات
ستبدا سلطه النظام في التاكل لذا كثيرا ما
يستشهد من اي بانهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
خلال عهد غربتشا بسببي تدخلات الغرب
ومؤامته ويحاول اسقاط ما حدث حينها على
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه المتكرره لكن كل هذا
لا يغلق الباب امام فكره التغيير
الاختياري قبل الاضطرار للتغيير الاجباري
وربما تكون شرطه الاخلاق اول من يدفع
الثمن ثمان التغيير بسبب سمعتها السيئه
هذا فضلا عن ان النساء بدانا في تحديها
بشكل واسع واصرنا يسرنا في الشوارع من
دوني حجاب
[موسيقى]